[موسيقى]
زياره دوله يتم تنظيمها في واشنطن للحليب
الاقدم فرنسا تهدف الى تقويه العلاقات بين
الشريكين التقليديين والى طي صفحه ازمه
الغواصات الاستراليه بالاضافه الى تقريب
وجهات النظر حول ازمه عده
فرنساوي
نحن نتشارك نفس القيم ونتصدى معا للتحديات
احيانا يكون لدينا بعض الاختلافات الطفيفه
ولكن ليس بشكل اساسي
ابرز الملفات الخلافيه بين البلدين التي
من المنتظر ان يتم ايجاد حل لها في هذه
الزياره هي السياسه الاقتصاديه التي
اتخذها الرئيس الامريكي والتي وصفها
ماكرون بشديده العدوانيه ضد الشركات
الاوروبيه عندما وضع بيضا برنامج المعونات
الحكوميه للشركات الامريكيه ما اعتبره
الفرنسيون مناقضا لقانون التجاره الحره
وتهديدا بتفتيت الغرب
ولكننا في نفس الوقت ندعم الجيش الاوكراني
والشعب الاوكراني الذي يرغب بالمقاومه نحن
نشكر الولايات المتحده على دعمها
لاوكرانيا
تؤثر على الاراضي الاوروبيه بشكل مباشر
الى جانب هذه المحادثات عبر الرئيسان ايضا
عن رايهما في مخص اوكرانيا الذي يتجلى
التباين الفرنسي الامريكي في موقف ماكرون
من الحوار مع موسكو حين تركيه في ذلك
مئاتيا الامر الذي يزعجه واشنطن لكن الملف
الايراني
من حيازه او تطوير سلاح النووي
في مؤتمرهما الصحفي شدد الرئيسان على
الاجواء الاجرابيه بينهما والمحايه لان كل
الملفات الخلفيه ربما حلت ونتعون سينا في
الايام المقبله وسيصل الى مستويات لم يسبق
ان وصلها انها الرساله التي اراد الرئيس
بعيدا ايصالها خاصه بعد هذا الاستقبال
الرسمي
والحفاوته بالرئيس الفرنسي
[موسيقى]
اريد سليمان العربيه واشنطن